Alex: Wooo we are live and I have a graveyard to show you. Welcome back to The Office 360 Unfiltered. I am Alex. Last week we talked about keys. Who owns the repo. Today is about the leads you already paid to get, and how they die in a contact form that emails nobody. Come on. If your site is pretty and your inbox is empty, this one is going to sting in a useful way.
Morgan: Ha, I have the autopsy. I'm Morgan. Picture a gorgeous homepage. Video background. Forty-seven plugins. And the only door for a human being is a form that says send, and then it mails an intern who left in twenty twenty-three. No CRM. No follow up. No owner. Authors, schools, churches, you ran ads into that hole. That is not a marketing problem. That is architecture with a missing pipe.
Alex: Exactly. At The Office 360 we obsess over three-click discoverability, and then we obsess over what happens after click three. Book. Event. Donate. The form cannot be a trap door. It has to land in a system with a name on it. A CRM. A sequence. A human who actually answers. Four seniors, Lisbon to New York. We do not ship a pretty funnel that dumps water on the floor.
Morgan: And the funny-sad part is agencies love to sell you more traffic. More ads. More SEO retainers. Meanwhile the bucket has a hole. We audited a publisher who spent real money on a campaign and every lead sat in a spam folder named info at. No tags. No book title. No, hey, you asked about the hardcover. Just a graveyard. When we rebuild it, the form is short, the thank you is honest, and the lead is in the CRM before they close the tab.
Alex: That is the whole product. Fixed scope. You own the code. You own the list. Automated so it does not depend on one intern's Gmail. If a visitor cannot hit the thing in three clicks, we failed. If they hit it and nobody answers, we also failed. Same standard as last week. If you cannot leave with your data, you do not own it. Don't rent your leads to a contact form.
Morgan: And this is why this episode is sponsored by Klear. Klear with a K. Same joke. Don't swallow the heavy version that sits there and does nothing. Traditional protein is chalk and bloating. Klear is clear whey isolate. You can see it. Twenty grams of protein, zero sugar, zero lactose, about ninety calories. We earn a commission if you use our code. That keeps this live show on the air, and I would rather say that out loud.
Alex: Two cities, long days, I am not dumping a milkshake into a form that goes nowhere. Strawberry watermelon. Wild blue raspberry. One scoop, twelve ounces of water, shake, let it settle a minute, drink it like a sports drink. Exclusive twenty percent off. Code MARKETPL. klearprotein.com/discount/MARKETPL. Use that link. Same rule as the CRM. Use the pipe that actually delivers.
Morgan: Homework. Open your own site on your phone. Fill the form. See who gets the email. See if your name, your book, your event even shows up. If it dies, call us. theoffice360.com. Code STUDIO50. Fifty percent off the studio tiers. Email theofficetechies@gmail.com. Four people. You own the work. You own the list.
Alex: Authors, schools, publishers, churches. Traffic is vanity if the door is a graveyard. We build the three-click path and we wire the follow through. No junior maze. No retainer to babysit a form. When the invoice is paid, the house is yours, and the leads are yours. Clean sites. Clean fuel. That is the whole vibe of this show.
Morgan: If your protein still tastes like chalk, Klear, klearprotein.com, code MARKETPL, twenty percent off. If your contact form emails a ghost, you know where we live. I'm Morgan, he's Alex, this was The Office 360 Unfiltered, sponsored in part by Klear. We love you. Bye!